حسنًا الوضع الإنساني في
السودان أه يزداد سوءًا مع
مرور كل أسبوع مع
استمرار القتال وتوسعه إلى
مناطق جديدة أه مثل ما مدني على سبيل
المثال ثاني أكبر مدينة في السودان
حوالي
90 أه ميل جنوب شرق كرم والتي
كانت مؤخرًا  اتخاذها من قبل قوات الدعم السريع
يزيد فقط أه
صعوبات إيصال
المساعدات الإنسانية للسودانيين المحتاجين كان لديك
بالفعل مئات الآلاف من
السودانيين الذين فروا من كروم إلى ود
مدني والآن يفرون من ود مجنون
إلى الجنوب وهو  مما يجعل من
الصعب جدًا على
الوكالات الإنسانية بما في ذلك جميع
منظمات الأمم المتحدة تقديم المساعدة
للمحتاجين أه
كما أن قوات الدعم السريع لها سمعة
أه خلق المزيد من المشاكل عن طريق
النهب وأخذ المثليين من المدنيين
أه والاستيلاء على منازلهم  أم انتهاك المرأة
وأه إنه حتما
سيكون الوضع أسوأ حيث أه الأسابيع
الماضية كانت هناك مزاعم كثيرة
عن العنف الجنسي ضد المرأة في
السودان أه ليس لدي شك في أن ما أه
هناك هذه القضية دقيق ولكن هناك  لقد
كانت هناك العديد من الحالات الأخرى
خاصة في منطقة الدرور حيث
أصبحت المشكلة شبه نظامية في
وقت واحد أه يعني هذا واضح أه يؤدي إلى
تفاقم المشكلة وهو
أحد الأسباب وراء
هروب الكثير من العائلات السودانية من أماكن مثل ود
مدني لأنهم  خائفين من أن
يكون هناك انتهاكات للنساء
والأسر لذلك هذه
مشاكل خطيرة أه وهي
مستمرة منذ أشهر في السودان هذا
ليس بالأمر الجديد وبعض هذه الحالات
تم توثيقها بشكل جيد للغاية
وكل ما يفعله هو تفاقم  ش
العداء بين
المدنيين السودانيين من جهة وتلك
القوات المسلحة من جهة أخرى أنه من
الضروري أن تتيح كل من
القوات المسلحة السودانية وقوات الدعم السريع أه
الدولية أه
والمنظمات غير الحكومية المحلية
وهؤلاء أه فروع تلك العناصر من
الأمم المتحدة التي هي في
وضع يمكنها من تقديم
المساعدة الإنسانية للسماح لهم بذلك
للسماح لهم بالتحرك على نظام الطريق
والانتقال إلى مناطق مثل الكارتوم وود
مدني التي كانت كذلك  لقد دمروا الآن
في الأشهر الأخيرة ودعهم يقومون
بعملهم،
محظورين حتى يتمكنوا على
الأقل من تلبية احتياجات شعب السودان